hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play my little
foundation containment is magic
since this team dries raise such a
kerfuffle kerfuffle
I believe that kerfuffle would be the
correct word sorry I just need to change
something here something has gone
horribly awry there we go
huh so now we are going to be getting
back into war whoa my shave game is gone
Wow alright whatever I guess this is a
return of marca pony hey man the party
cannon what ok anyway man people were
like really upset in the last comment
section I was surprised oh wow
I'm gonna play it anyway I mean I'm
still not a brony still haven't been
transmissions board if ember no I have
not been transformed into one of them
but I still find this game funny I help
you guys - this gave us hilarious if
it's injected with ponies that's just
damn funny what wouldn't it be funny it
is funny isn't it ok maybe it's uh come
on
all right we are in the game
ah containment is magic got it
wait hey come on there we go Oh starting
right with the bathroom thank you very
much
ha ha what are you doing here
bye shut up shut up toilet man lady oh
I'm not going through there I just know
that pinkie pie was it I think was
pinkie pie you guys said a pass was that
oh yeah I forgot oh it's a pony gonna
this is the one that appears out of the
corner of your eye is gonna is it gonna
start having ponies the corn in my eye
speaking of in my eye oh my god
something is in my eye I'm about to
start tearing up oh I got it hurts so
bad but the show must go on
ha ha did my eyeballs aah
okay I can dig it it's just a tear gas
Oh make it stop the strong dollar crap
do not see the tears that are streaming
down my face cuz something just went in
my eye
god dammit
can you see the tears that are now
streaming down my face
probably not but oh ah what just what
the hell could have possibly gone into
my eyeball ah it's gonna be going to me
the magic it's too much
the ponies I can't take it okay that's
better
ah now that my eyes are all puffy and
red let's carry on with this and take
off this gas Mac it did not help
cuz stuff Dell went in my eyeballs it's
still there but I will persevere oh my
god this is my I can't handle oh yeah
this is Andy well let's see here I'm
glad that this is right here so let's
speed our way coming girl and nothing
else fall into my eyeballs fine go oh
man how rough I was really rough I don't
know I really don't know what it was
dr. glam calm shouter dr. Twilight
Sparkle don't care ah ah man it burns
the birds with the fire of a thousand
suns no I'm not gonna take a break
UK me I go in er uninterrupted for the
duration of this let's play and I will
not stop for anybody especially of
foreign objects inside my eyeballs
that's almost better I have the
fortitude of a yak and the constitution
of a gerbil
a really big gerbil like bag gerbil okay
all right
at least it's made this process of
upgrading my card entertaining or
something
ah I burned some okay I'm okay hello
anomalous thingamabob er whatever the
hell you are
okay
that was weird you're just gonna ignore
that okay I don't need to go back from
now on cuz everything behind me is just
a dead end a PS oh no wait I thought
that was gonna be tear gas here oh good
I can hardly take anything else going
into my eye
this is your guess ah piss I didn't
change in mind my mask into a super mask
got to do that real quick God do that
one last thing before I get on my way
cuz I need that super mask and if I had
my map I'd make a super map but I don't
have either of those things so I don't
know what I'm gonna do dude let whippet
ow
Oh I'll tell you what there's something
in your eye will certainly wake you up
cuz I was like yo ah let's do another
let play oh this is gonna be great
ah what the hell oh that's bad not like
Pony screaming Rainbow Dash I think
that's what it was ah no no yo
as much distance between me and that
monster cut I can pass it down there she
he she I think there's a she cuz Pinkie
Pie would suggest a feminine name where
you are you're down that New York town
right there you know
hi aren't you adorable Rosie go there
you gonna kill me you gonna give me a
great big hug Collier I'm ready for it
back at so much hug well fudger nutters
now stupid now stupid the booboo pants
all right where are you on your oh no
uh-huh
we're what the hell topic get away from
there
get away aha
you're moved I heard you move where you
know ah that yeah okay here we go yep
no there you are and here I go ha ha
finally I made sweet that's damned jar
you dick oh yeah Augie so prayer I hear
you're moving around in there what oh no
oh you gotta be joking me but there was
nowhere else to go no it was literally
nowhere else to go was there okay that's
good right there stay there
where are you there you are stay there
okay aah demon Pony oh I know where to
go you just stand there
there was this area down here are not
here but down in the next area
there's a way down that I can go I don't
want to go no is there yeah there is
okay
I don't wanna but I can't stay away yeah
piss we're yet I know you're down here
somewhere just got a blow to you where
are you where are you where are you
where are you where are ya oh you're not
here are you not here well why aren't
you here uh uh uh uh uh I guess ya not
pass now you're in there [ __ ] saving
to try to save my ass go away no one
likes you
no one likes I'll come on oh I hate this
one I do not like this gay girl I don't
remember the river of tears I don't
remember that at all
no I cares you're unloved stay that way
please this is Alex from sub super
yeah what the hell is that I don't
remember that you ass off oh yes I'm
back here not that uh no the tunnels
like bad I got nowhere else to go
there's literally nowhere nowhere that I
could possibly go so long as Pinkie Pie
isn't down here too I should be able to
run with the SuperSpeed to the other
place okay I just got to get to the
other end of the tunnel and then escape
from the blue one and I should be fine
no Pinkie Pie sightings yet it's awfully
dark oh here it is there's the door now
I just got it where's the damn button
maybe it's not that one
aha Josh seem to be locked I just gotta
wait until ah go let it go in it ba ba
ba ba go go yes yes yeah yeah yeah take
it down blue bastard laughing night out
hey go away go away go away going save
yeah yeah so Pro so bro what is this
what is this man
there we go [ __ ] good thing piggy by
one-hitter what's the name of the other
one what is the name of the other one I
forget I'm going save what what is that
can't see oh it's a dead body
I remember they put in dead bodies I
don't need to go in there either still
get away from what - who's it's cuz I
can hear the epic strings ah ha there we
go ha ha I'm too fell gob so well
MLG up in here so great at everything
god okay I got my level 5 doodad take
this off don't need to run anymore
get up ma let's sex 8 to being all rowdy
shout out I'm coming down man you can't
be harshing my buzz breath okay so if
this is here that means the computer
doodad is nearby which means that I
should almost hang on let me put a
battery into this not an elbow at all
I'm not going through there again you
better have something for me here yes
uh-huh I'm gonna go through here again
there's no nothing here okay
oh hey hi there aren't you adorable
let's go down come on I can go around
him if if you stay right there I can go
around you right correct
correctomundo Colette hi
okay Kimmie can't get me douche where's
the exit Oh where's a freaking exit I
got her honor what that wait a minute
where where's the exit where's the exit
where's the freaking tags at where our
other dams ha ha ha
yes ah
goose stop it right there
no thank you
why is Pinkie Pie made out of concrete
as well okay let's just get through here
save this cut this down and then try to
see there's some progress to be made
yes this is it I want to see what this
is before I get out of this episode what
this guy is what person he look like a
goat on is not that hello dead guy
woop get me through up hiss hey I was
trying to run her up
what the hell you son of a [ __ ] I will
make it through there I've made it
through before wait no do I have to turn
off the electronics yes did I screw up
ah oh shut up a [ __ ] weren't able to
get through here god damn it I thought I
could maybe if I had my super runners
sound is weird
- hmm whoa dad what the hell was that
okay it looks like I might have to get
back and turn off the power and then
turn it back on that's right okay ah
that's right I forgot
I forgot a step anyway I'm all that time
for now so I will pick this up again
later because I will finish out this
pony infested thing and don't worry
about my eyeballs they're fine now thank
you for being so concerned about me
so thank you for watching and thank you
everybody for watching click the
annotation for videos that I've done I
forgot my order there and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
the Jennifer
Oh
but
Wow